i'm here today to talk about my big idea
which is the importance of candor and
business investors when i talk to
investors they will all tell me that i
want to know what the bottom line of the
company is in order to make a decision
about whether i invest in that company i
think about the bottom line why not a
bottom line is a number so it's very
precise but is it accurate and what we
have found through doing research over
the past 10 years is that words matter
as much as numbers in determining the
investment potential because words tell
you about the candor of a company which
reveals the underlying trustworthiness
of a corporate culture so if you have a
culture like an Enron then you're going
to be more mistrustful of the numbers if
the business is like a Berkshire
Hathaway you're going to be more
trusting of the numbers it's it's so
interesting the word candor means
different things to different people I
find that most often people talk about
candor as meaning the whole truth
telling the whole truth all the time but
candor means not just that you are being
accurate in what you're saying but
you're being authentic the lack of
candor which we call fog standing for
fact efficient obfuscating generalities
it's an acronym I mean you you probably
want to know why it really is this
important it doesn't really matter if
people aren't being clear in what
they're saying does it matter if their
grammar is tortured and they're using
words jargony words like you're
streamlining our enterprise for to
accelerate our momentum in our project
trajectory I mean does it really matter
if people are communicating like that it
matters a great deal and why simply if
if you hear people talking like that if
you're in a company you're not quite
clear on but how you should be spending
your time you're not quite clear about
what is the direction of the business
you're wondering what is it about the
leadership that they're not able to
speak to you simply and directly and
give
you a sense of not only where you're
coming from but where you're going how
does one how does one actually decode
CEO communication it's going to shock
you it's so easy it's it's it's quite
extraordinary now let me give you an
example here is a here's a passage from
Enron's last shareholder letter they
wrote our talented people global
presence financial strength and massive
market knowledge have created our
sustainable unique businesses what have
I learned from that not very much and I
will tell you that as the letter goes on
there is really no further development
of these ideas in a way that's logical
and context heavy so right off the bat I
advise people if you're reading one of
these communications take a red pen and
start circling the jargony words start
circling the cliches start circling the
words that are really not adding much if
any meaning to the undo your
understanding of the business these
letters reveal the personality of the
person who's writing the letter think
about it every person in the world has a
unique thumbprint nobody else in the
world has it similarly a corporation a
company has a corporate thumbprint
there's something that's unique and
special about that company the culture
and when that is revealed in a
shareholder communication that is
something that builds trust builds
engagement with with the stakeholders
and again is really important for the
sustainability of that business but
really in the real world what does it
translate into does it really improve
market performance for the past seven
years we have rank or degree every year
we create a benchmark survey of 100
companies in the fortune 500 we use code
and score each company for the presence
of candor the percentage of candor
percent percentage of fog and then we
rank order the company's high to low for
the past seven years we found that this
top quartile of companies ranked highest
and candor have consistently
outperformed on average the company's
ranked lowest in the lowest quartile of
candor and also the market the sp500 and
that's includes boom markets and bus
markets